imagine you're a sailor
working on a great lakes freighter for
two months at a time
and you need your mail delivered
well that's where we come in
my name is jim hogan and i'm the owner
and the fourth generation of the jw
westcott company
this company was started in 1874 by my
great grandfather captain john ward
westcott
we operate a
shorter ship and ship to shore delivery
boat in the port of detroit we're the
only floating zip code in actually the
united states and it still holds true
today any package that's got that 48222
zip code is going to arrive here at our
station
on any given day we receive the mail and
packages in the morning you see the
various pigeon holes as they were called
each of those represent different ships
we place mail in those slots and we wait
until the vessel is actually coming
through the port of detroit
hey dorothy ann how you doing today
pretty good how about yourself no not
too bad just getting finished up here
okay real good let's see a little bit
we packed the mailbags
captain takes the vessel away from our
dock
and off the midstream we go
we deliver mail by the pail and that's
the sailor's mailbox if you will the
crewmen aboard the ship will lower down
a bucket and we'll fill the bucket with
the mail
and then we send the bucket back up
sometimes we're delivering passengers
crew
we had a grocery order a number of years
ago the last item was about three and a
half feet long i looked at it was a tuna
a whole tuna
we end the delivery with a salute
we head back to the dock and wait for
our next adventure
i've worked here for 43 years i'm
grateful to have been a part of all of
this and i look forward to a fifth
generation taking this on
and
seeing where it goes
up or down the river as it were
you